ugandan opposition politician kisa
beside is used to being arrested
for more than 20 years he's demonstrated
against the government of president
yoweri museveni and challenged him in
four elections his protest on monday was
against the rising cost of living
at the fuel pumps prices have gone up 70
percent in the last year
food prices are climbing too
motorbike taxi riders are among millions
whose livelihoods are affected
what used to be five dollars a while ago
is now fourteen dollars they should
reduce the price of fuel
president museveni has ruled uganda ever
since he led a rebellion and took power
by force in 1986 he's rejected some of
the ideas to bring down prices removing
taxes
or subsidizing many of the imports is
suicidal
and a blunder
how then we fund our budget for the
roads
electricity schools
medicine
security atc
beside who also protested last week says
it's corruption rather than public
spending that's draining government
coffers
arrest those who have taken our money
the thieves they are known return their
property so that it serves the people
who are in crisis if we are able to do
certain things
then we can immediately take
steps
that quickly relieve people
his attempt attempted demonstration also
promptly ended in his arrest
for more than 10 years uganda's
government has tried to stop street
protests before crowds can even gather
meanwhile the cost of living keeps
rising as it is in many countries but
about 40 percent of ugandans live on
less than two dollars a day and can't
afford to pay more
malcolm webb al jazeera